bon et comme c'est la première fois
qu'on joue à répercuter review première
fois
premier souvenir des thoniers je pense
que ça serait vraiment ma première scène
en fait tout simplement parce que ça a
été beaucoup de stress pour moi et je
m'en rappelle encore donc c'est vraiment
le souvenir qui me revient là dans
laquelle son premier objet fétiche
ben en fait c'est un grigri que j'ai
toujours et que j'ai trouvé il ya à peu
près trois ans avec l'homme avec qui je
suis aujourd'hui on la trouvait au bord
de la route et on a senti vu ce que
c'était ce que c'était une matière un
petit peu quoi c'est quoi un petit peu
comme la sorcellerie
ce gaillard ce que c'est ce que j'ai
peur que ça marche plus après mais une
matière voyez comme les dans les trucs
comme ça mais d'animal c'est pas un truc
d'êtres humains qu'on a trouvé et c'est
une matière vivante en fait qu'on a
trait au bord de la route et c'était pas
celle du tout c'est pour ça qu'il a
ramassé ainsi à activer ses voix sur la
taxe non non je ne dirais pas ce qu'est
ce que je suis très superstitieuse mais
voilà c'est ça c'est un grigri en fait
que je mets dans une petite boîte donc
sceptique comme ça non par contre je
perds tout donc tous mes trucs porte
bonheur tout maigrir et que j'allais sur
la barre mais je me mets en relation
avec le voilà pour les péchés
franchement j'ai tellement sage moi je
n'aime pas l'alcool
on va dire ces cigarettes simplement
quand j'avais 14 ans parce que le reste
tout ce qui est c'est que je veux dire
c'est pas dépêcher pour moi un problème
quelqu'un qu'on est bien avec lui c'est
pas un péché je ne parlerai pas de ça
tout seul ça a pêché non on frise bassir
canon cgt
ils terrer comme olivier chez les curés
donc pour nous tous tes péchés n'est-ce
pas tout ce qui apporte du bonheur est
pêché voilà c'est ça
24 mai et juin
dépêchez vous j'ai cambriolé maison
quand j'avais 8 ans 1
première belle robe première belle robe
vraiment la première très très belle
c'était dans le métier quand j'ai fait
une cérémonie
c'était une remise de prix en fait
c'était comme les nrj music awards mais
une autre chaîne
donc vous n'avez pas quoi mais j'avais
vraiment une droite dure le monde des
autres chaînes
je préfère pas quand même à bord j'ai
choisi la jeunesse show business wire
les discussions des chaînes concurrentes
si ça pouvait dire jamais vu ça ici m6
se voir le premier baiser premier baiser
j'avais 12 ans et je peux dire son nom
c'était yoann et ça s'est très bien
passé fin j'étais vraiment intimidé je
me rappelle que quand on a commencé à
s'embrasser en était debout et à la fin
j'ai ouvert les yeux et j'étais en fait
à six ans les marges escaliers parce
qu'on était à l'arrêt bus et donc je
sais pas comment je me suis retrouvé à
six comme ça mais il a dû se passer un
tourbillon et qui m'a fait tomber quoi
c'est assez impressionnant avec la
langue ou semblant quand vous mettez pas
la langue tout de suite olivier on ne
met pas la langue
premier flirt poussé premier faire
pousser je devais avoir dix sept ans et
c'était en fait dans une ruelle juste en
face de chez moi donc je me rappelle que
je devais rentrer et ma mère était au
balcon et alizée je l'entendais dire à
mon père mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait et
devrait déjà être là et du coup moi ça
me réussit et forcément de savoir mes
parents me chercher et on s'est mis dans
que contre la russe 1 contre le mur et
là c'est vrai que ça a été la première
fois qu'ils étaient un peu plus poussées
mais justement on n'est pas passé à
l'acte première fois alors très très
poussée ouais première fois avec un
garçon 18 ans donc c'était un an après
la première fois poussé et c'est
toujours la même ah ouais ils sont
fidèles c'est incroyable les premières
fois avec une fille
jamais un bon j'ai que 21 ans le
meilleur et plus venir je pense comme
toi 3 janet non plus jamais oser
beaucoup de choses à dire
jean faure à vous raconter ma vie est
telle que des découvertes
premier chagrin d'amour
j'en ai eu pas mal hein ouais peut-être
il a commencé dernier treize ans après
que j'ai eu mon premier garçon à deux
premières tentatives de suicide jamais
où ça mais c'est pas prêt grave je
regarde maman je m'en remets toujours
premiers valium témesta lexomil drogue
je n'aime pas de joindre la droite d'où
son laitière oui j'oubliais première
infidélité
oui c'est vrai qu'avant bah justement
c'était à mes 17 ans il m'est arrivé
carrément de sortir avec 3 mais quand
même
mais je me sentais que c'était pas des
rétro satanas
il ne savait pas heureusement donc ça va
je dirais ça le week-end
pour nous poser